guys if we all come together and even
give one pound and reach our 10 000 gold
300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
salam eats yes brothers and sisters you
can choose whatever you want brothers
and sisters your local halal restaurants
around the corner in your neighborhood
inshallah chico's is one of those i've
went to amazing food alhamdulillah
download them now and find your halal
spots assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends so habib came out and said
that these ring girls are absolutely
useless
do i agree with them 100
now when we say useless are we talking
about
the female
within and within herself
no we're talking about what she's doing
or what she's told to do or let's
suppose and say what she chooses to do
you know choose
if you don't have a
if you are told how to think how could
you make the right choices with your
free will let's get straight into the
video and here is what he had to say
[Music]
what is
no
or do they help people to see that is
the second round
no
which it comes to later makes a very
good point what are they doing is this
right what is their purpose
if you think about it what he's saying
is very true how many people are looking
at these ring ladies
putting up
the
the round two round three sign who the
hell is looking at round two
yeah who who needs anybody to say this
round two let's be real and be honest
because that's what i love about khabib
yeah i love people that are honest and
to the point he's not he's cut into the
chase not being around the bush and he's
simply saying that these girls what is
it their purpose
except being sexually objectified why do
they have to come out in underwear let's
not call it bikini let's not call it hot
pants or whatever it is underwear that
is what you wear
in your private gathering well not in
the times that we live in this book here
i recommend every single female email to
reader i'm going through this book here
it is damn amazing it breaks down how
beautiful
women are
and i'm gonna go through some things
because it's gonna be so beneficial guys
beside being an eye candy for all these
perverted men who just want to watch you
and sexualize you literally they are
raping you with their eyes
they are systematically raping you with
their eyes and the amount of people that
watch pornography and you already
dehumanized
shows that not only that these women
that abused abused how by these
mma fighters etc not all but they are
taking advantage of okay now yes some
women might be there as gold diggers or
whatever and you can say they love it no
you can see that this is the biggest
scam and all they are being used is for
their body because why don't they have
someone who may be a little bit
overweight doing that showing the which
rounds it is because what is
unattractive so now you have a beauty i
do and people are starving their self
trying to look a certain way unhappy
literally starving the same self most of
their life to have the perfect body and
you are here to tell us that the muslim
woman are subjugated and oppressed and
we need to free them muslim women are
free because they enslave themselves to
the creator who's deserving of worship
and they cover their self so men can
talk to them and see them as human
beings because men are visual men are
visual creatures brothers and sisters
if you think about it
the hijab yeah or what allah orders a
woman to wear okay allah doesn't say
that muslim woman should wear the hijab
or whether abaya because men can't
control their self and their animals no
that's nonsense because allah tells a
believing man to lower the gaze a man
has to lower the gaze we shouldn't be
looking at that period let me read
something some stuff from this book so
this author renee angel
has a phd
um said
basically did a study and the study was
the following i gave over 100 young
women at lloyd university chicago the
following instructions many researchers
have studied what the ideal woman looks
like according to our society's
standards take a moment to think about
what this cultural ideal woman looks
like and describe her now please take a
moment to imagine that you look just
like the woman you just described think
about the ways in which you believe your
life would be different if you look like
this woman how would things change for
you that was the question and this is
what follows this is what she said the
response was so upsetting that i
considered stopping the study early one
young woman told us that if she could
just be beautiful she would finally be
able to focus on her inner abilities and
talent
my gosh
and that is what a woman is you are more
than your beauty your inner talent
should shine and that is what this is
the reason why islam tells a woman to
cover so men do not fall in love with
the wrong way or want you for other
reasons yeah okay and they are focused
on your face speaking to you even then
they slow it again speaking to you not
you yeah not what your you know your
assets or whatever you want to call it
yeah another said she might genuinely
feel happy most of the time instead of
just faking it my gosh imagine living
like that a different young woman
explained that if she could just look
the way our culture wants women to look
she would never had an eating disorder
causing the stress on everyone around
her not just her people that suffer
along with her over 70 of women in the
study said they'll be treated better
by by others if they looked the beauty
ideal
my gosh and you're telling me muslim
women are enslaved let's go
up unequal surveyed over 200 000 young
people in 42 different countries i was
saddened but not surprised to read that
among 15 year olds in every country
surveyed girls more more likely than
boys to report they were too fat and
unhappy one 36 year old woman i spoke to
estimated that she had been on a diet
for somewhere between a third and a half
of her life
responding to her careful over having
her body airbrushed thinner on the cover
of flair actress jennifer lawrence
recently called out to those who those
who fat-shamed in an interview with
yahoo ceo marissa mayer lawrence asked
what are you going to do be hungry every
single day to make other people happy
careful reviews of weight loss research
suggests that for most people the only
way to permanently diet your way to
significantly lower weight is to be
willing to remain hungry every single
day so what khabib said is absolutely
right these women are absolutely useless
in the sense they are useless in the
sense that the job that they're doing
it's like me coming and saying get
someone and be like just stand here half
naked in your pants and just put up a
science and cheeseburgers yeah you have
nothing to do with the cheeseburger
nothing but i am using you as a piece of
meat yet to lure people in
if you are not treated as a piece of
meat by this industry i don't know what
being used means we need to find a new
definition so what khabib said is
absolutely damn on point these women are
not useless
they are human beings they should be
respected and
treated well and that's why islam has
regulations that when you want to marry
a woman there's things that are in place
to honor them yes to honor a woman
but sadly in today's time men use these
women how they please how they like they
are used in all kinds of industries the
pornography industry
you name it yeah they are used and
abused and they choose this and
brainwash you to the level that in my
jahilia they used to be girls in the
clubs that i used to go and they the
rapper is saying
excuse my language yeah the rappers will
say
you i don't know these hoes etc or
whatever and they will be like yeah and
i'm thinking my gosh i'm thinking now
like i was a jacket that was an absolute
ignoramus there as well
yeah and these rap music these
industries dehumanize women yeah woman
became a human in my eyes when i came to
islam they became human yeah before that
they were nothing but sexual objects
i'll be real with you and these women
dancing in the night clubs and saying
yeah i'm a
whole this time i'm thinking what's why
what the hell who does that who does
that to systematically being brainwashed
that you ascribe a word that is from a
is given to a promiscuous woman who
sleeps around and you're like yeah i'm
i'm a whole and i'm like
my gosh
my gosh the level of brainwashing so
much so that when the truth comes to you
you see it as being oppressed
and true freedom is only achieved
by worshiping allah till next time if
you've enjoyed this video
share it with your friends and family
assalamu alaikum barack obama